it's the year 2024 and people are still
having the debate about R and python
which one is better which one should you
learn if you're getting into data
science and who's using what well watch
till the very end because I'm going to
cover all of those things I'm Richard
and this is Richard on data so four
years ago I did a video on exactly this
topic I overviewed the popularity and
the capabilities of both of these
languages as well as the relative
learning curve for beginners and the
conclusion that I came to was that if
you absolutely must pick one pick python
But ultimately you should pick one of
the two get really good at it and then
move on and learn the other well things
change fast and 4 years is a relatively
long period of time so I'm going to go
over all these things again and you'll
see if after 4 years my recommendation
has shifted at all before I do that 70%
of you who watch my videos aren't
subscribed so if you aren't please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already then take just a fraction of a
second to smash the like button for the
YouTube algorithm so let's start by
talking about who's using which language
and which one is the most popular both
inside and outside of the data Science
World this is going to depend on the
methodology that you're using as well as
who you're asking but the most common
index used for measuring the popularity
of programming languages Remains the
toobi index and the results for this in
January of 2024 are pretty fascinating
so the toobi index works by looking at
search queries across variety of search
engines as well as the number of courses
and third-party vendors for that
language that's essentially used as a
proxy of the languages prevalence and
popularity and you'll see that python is
quite literally the most popular
programming language in the world and
where does our stack up well it's not
even close when I did this video before
it was sitting at number 18 but today
again this is in January of 2024 it's
sitting at number 23 three just a little
bit above SAS now it's important to take
all of this with a grain of salt because
it's not a totally Apples to Apples
comparison reason being python is a
general purpose programming language
whereas R was literally built by
statisticians for other statisticians so
it's almost exclusively used for data
science and statistics and there's also
some indices out there that give
somewhat different results an example of
one of those would be PPL that is the
popularity of programming language index
not to be confused with pii which is the
python package Index this one is
strictly created by analyzing how often
tutorials for that language are searched
for on Google and you'll see again
python sits way at the top and it's not
particularly close not surprising but R
is all the way up at number six on this
one which is very different from number
23 so it's easy and frankly quite fair
to look at these things and think okay I
don't really care what are people
actually using in their jobs or what
should I learn so that I maximize my own
chances of getting a job so it was
surprisingly hard to find recent
reliable analyses that broke down job
listings for these Technologies
specifically for data science the best
thing that I could find was anaconda's
mid 2022 state of data science report so
Anaconda does this report every year and
it's a fairly comprehensive methodology
they're surveying people from all around
the globe from different Industries in
some different titles but also people at
different stages of their careers so
anaconda's findings shouldn't be super
surprising what they find is 31% of the
survey participants always use Python
27% of them frequently use it and 22%
sometimes use it you add that up and
that's 80% of participants
using python at least some of the time
if not all of the time so that's
absolutely enormous when you look at R
by contrast though 7% of participants
always use it 19% frequently use it and
28% sometimes use it that's a total of
54% so that's definitely quite a
significant gap between the two
interestingly rounding out the middle
there is SQL with 16% 26% and 29 % in
those respective categories making up a
total of
71% so if you take one thing away from
this python is used even more than SQL
now so I hope I've established pretty
clear and convincing evidence from both
the indices as well as anaconda's report
that python is used by Far and Away more
than R is and I really don't see that
changing to be fair sometimes what
people use is going to be influenced by
what they learned in school because you
become comfortable with one technology
and you might be reluctant to change to
something else unless you have a job
that forces you to I can't find any
up-to-date research on what colleges are
teaching in the year
2024 but from my own experience as well
as anecdotes from people I've talked to
it seems common that people use R when
they're in statistics and data analysis
courses and they Learn Python when
they're in programming and computer
science courses but then that you don't
know either of them one of the natural
first questions you might ask is which
one of the two is easier to learn this
is honestly a highly subjective question
which there's a lot of disagreement and
Arguments for both sides on this
personally I found python to be by far
the more difficult of the two to pick up
but again this is probably influenced by
college experience I personally did
statistics programs for both my bachelor
and my masters and I used r in quite
literally every single course so after a
while for me using R was as natural as
breathing when I learned python it was
definitely a little more challenging to
manage environments as well as packages
and conflicts so that was a major thing
for me but I have heard people make the
exact opposite points I've heard people
pick up Python and they say it's the
simplest and cleanest and easiest thing
to use ever but then they go to learn R
and they find it abstract and weird so
it's really impossible to definitively
say for you which one would be easier to
learn unless you really firmly lean in
one Camp versus the other that is
statistics background versus computer
science background and then for these
two languages what integrated
development environment or IDE or text
editor are people using in
2024 well PPL tracks this as well pip
finds that visual studio and visual
studio code are right at the top
and those probably represent a lot of
people who use Python now things like py
charm and intell and Adam are pretty
popular choices as well vim and emac are
a little more old school but then our
studio is almost the universal choice of
environment for people who choose to use
R maybe for me it's sort of just old
habits dying hard but I've always found
our studio to be extremely easy to use
and to learn it's very good for keeping
yourself organized it's very flexible
and it just makes the whole programming
experience a joy so now let's talk about
capabilities and the Dirty Little Secret
here is that for both languages there is
usually at least one key package
sometimes multiple different packages
for doing almost anything that you want
that probably wasn't the case going back
four 5 years ago but in 2024 it pretty
much is let's take 2D visualization for
examp example so with r most people use
ggplot 2 for Python A lot of people will
use Matt plot lib sometimes people will
use caborn which is actually built on
top of matplot lib and sometimes in both
instances people will use plotly plotly
has implementations for both R and for
python R was literally built for
statistics and statistical modeling and
it has functions in base R just for that
python has stats models and and it's not
quite there yet in terms of maturity and
robustness to bugs and overall
capabilities but it's pretty close and
for the overwhelming majority of people
it'll get the job done for your standard
data manipulation type stuff in Python
the most popular option by far and away
is pandas although the newer polers is
catching up and for R you have the Tidy
verse although data table is sometimes
used for much larger data sets now this
is a pretty weird comparison to me
because pandas is a lot more
self-contained whereas the Tidy verse is
actually a pretty massive set of
packages so for instance de R for things
like joining or filtering or sorting you
have tidy R for reshaping you have per R
for looping and iteration the list goes
on again for most things that you're
doing either one of these two is going
to be just fine so I'll link to an
article that details some of the
differences between these two it's
generally agreed upon that pandas is a
little bit more clunky looking the
syntax isn't quite as nice and it's a
little harder to pick up but it is
faster now let's talk about web apps so
those of you who've been following me
for a while probably know that I'm a
large fan of making interactive web apps
especially compared to blowing up with
your environment with a bunch of
notebooks and to me the gold standard
has always been shiny shiny used to be a
totally R native project but there is
now an implementation of it in Python I
haven't personally gotten the chance to
use it yet but just know that option
does exist and you also have tons of
other options in Python for developing
and hosting apps so my personal favorite
is streamlet because it's so easy to
pick up and to use but you also have
Dash you have bokeh you have flask you
have more options than you'll probably
ever need and then for machine learning
the most popular framework in Python is
psyit learn for R there used to be the
carrot framework but more recently
that's sort of going by the way side in
favor of the newer and much easier to
use tidy models now there's plenty of
comparison tutorials out there
showcasing the differences between the
two in general I probably give a slight
nod to tidy models just because it
integrates so well with the overall tidy
verse ecosystem but overall both of the
two are pretty easy to use and I find
them both perfectly capable of doing
almost anything that I want them to
likewise if you're building neural
networks you have all kinds of options
in Python P torch is a big one as well
as tensor flow and Caris you also have
implementations of tensor flow and Caris
in R so we've covered a lot of analysis
type topics but a question a lot but
understandably not all people have is
okay what if you want to put something
into a production environment so I'll
actually start with r on this one R has
the plumber package which can be used
for generating and serving apis using R
functions and of course you could always
make and host shiny apps that's
literally how I worked for a little over
one year of my life but overall there's
no question you're going to find there's
a lot more options and support for
getting python based applications into
production compared to R you can
orchestrate pipelines using a framework
like airflow but then also if you're
deploying using one of the major cloud
service providers whether that's gcp or
AWS or Azure you'll find that those
software development kits are mostly
based around Python and this
consideration around production is
probably the single biggest reason if
you go to a major tech company or some
kind of software development Hub you're
much more likely to be working with
python than you are with r however and
this is a point that I make in a lot of
my videos not everybody breaking into
data science is necessarily interested
in that specific brand of data science
job there are a lot of people out there
and you have to ask yourself are you one
of these people who's more interested in
Academia and some people are more
interested in the healthcare or
biostatistics or pharmaceutical
Industries where R tends to be used the
most but I think it's beyond any
question or reasonable doubt that in
terms of total raw opportunities you are
going to have more of them out there
with python than you are with r so again
and if you're a total newcomer who
doesn't know either of the two that
definitely needs to enter into your
consideration when you're trying to pick
which one to learn something I've heard
people say for years which I still hear
to this day is that python is for
production whereas R is for research and
prototyping and I think there's certain
truth to that now one final comment I
want to make is that no programming
language lasts forever it's totally
possible that I come back in four to 5
years and make another video on this
topic and the takeaway is that both of
these two languages are in precipitous
decline Paving way for something else
but overall my advice really hasn't
changed that much from four years ago if
you have to pick between the two I
really do give the nod to python but
there are definitely some subjective
considerations here around things like
learning curve for you what you picked
up in school as well as what industries
you're most interested in and ultimately
I think what's most important is you
pick one of the two get really good at
it and then ideally move on and learn
the other one I personally found it
pretty instructive to get really good at
both of them and then try to study and
understand the programmatic differences
between the two but that's really
secondary after you get really good at
at least one of them so thanks for
watching this video If you enjoyed it
hit the like button if you didn't enjoy
it I guess you're free to hit the
dislike button if that's what you want
to do then leave me a comment down below
let me know what you think
do you like R more do you like python
more do you like Julia more than either
of those two let me know then I'll see
you all in the not so distant future
until then Richard on data